um I was going to ask you uh as somebody
who's from Puerto Rico I know you're
living in the States now
how do you feel about some of the like
uh people who are moving to Puerto Rico
for tax benefits
because I saw like I think the Paul
Brothers live there like Logan Paul
lives there I don't know well how does
it feel I mean there's some people that
are mad about it
yeah because I know some people are mad
but then some people are like well it
helps the economy a little it kind of
sheds no idea how to feel yeah I I I'm
the one that says that if you're if he
if it doesn't like harm people right and
do whatever you want to do do whatever
you think is better for you and yourself
because at the end of the day like you
can try to work four people you can try
to do everything for people but not
every people deserve so if you're like
if you're happy if you doing something
that you think is correct for your for
your I don't know for your money for
your for your you still have like a main
residence in Puerto Rico I don't my mom
my mom does you should have your address
as your mom's address so the U.S tax
thing you know they ain't in your
[__] piece yeah
I wish you live in Florida and there's
no state tax but I'd be like guys I live
in Puerto Rico my mom's address is my
address yeah no I I I I haven't done
that and then you put the Florida house
in your best friend's name yeah
yeah I could do that and then you just
you save money because [__] the IRS like
really you know what I mean I mean
you're right when does the album come
out uh
um probably we're working and we're
doing our best to drop it in October
October yeah very soon but I'm dropping
singles though that the first who do you
have on the album
right now it's just the the back door
remix with anuel Ryan Myers all of them
uh I'm trying to get luwal again which
is a trap artist too that he is in pacto
the original but he's gonna be I'm
trying to make him in a one of the sad
songs that I have okay I'm trying to get
a verse of him and he said yes he
already dropped the first part I haven't
like just structured the songs I have a
newbie which is a a new artist from
Puerto Rico and I have a couple more but
I can't say because I'm surprised okay
so album's coming in October Travis sir
go support it uh yo shout out to you and
your wife congratulations thank you so
much much much love and uh and and
prosperity to your marriage amen and
your wedding is coming December 2nd
December 2nd one of the most stressful
days of my wife's oh I've been married
before I mean I am married right now I
said like yeah you're [__] up in this
game
my wife don't watch this no it's a very
stressful you gotta get the Caterers you
got to get the food you got to pick the
flowers uh how much is your wedding
gonna cost
a couple hundred thousand uh half a
million
almost half a million what are we doing
here I don't know just buy a house yeah
you can buy like a yeah baby you have
almost half a million
she said
how much
Thirty hundred thirty three I mean a
thousand oh
we you're over budget if we're over
budget then yeah it's almost like when I
so when I get over budget on my wedding
I just started to uninvite people that's
what we're doing
I was like
when they told me okay look this is how
much it's gonna cost because you have
200 people coming I was like all right
well what is it if I have a hundred what
if I cut that in half
and they told me I was like all right
we're just gonna divide 100 people we're
trying to cut a lot of things but for
not like almost like 300 000 almost four
it's like it's like I said it's like
almost half a minute wow
you could buy a lot of uh a lot of lots
of things with that yeah it is a for me
it was one of the most important days of
my life in my wife's life so yeah
whatever it takes to make her happy and
make her like the Dream well the most
important day of your life was the
ceremony you had at your house because
now you guys are married exactly so this
is a really cool like also kind of cool
day to like you know give your wife her
dream wedding exactly yeah this is for
her this is for her yeah this is my
greatest gift right well you're so
romantic yes sir Jay wheeler the new
album's coming soon hopefully October
trappy trappy yeah appreciate you
pulling up brother thank you yes serving
me here